The Joe Rogan Experience I have enjoyed
your work with the Twitter file I enjoy
all your work but I really have enjoyed
the Twitter files that has been some
really fascinating views behind the
curtain it it's uh it's it's been one of
the weirder more surreal experiences of
my life because you know as a reporter
you you're always
um you kind of banging away to try to
get one little piece of reality right
like you might make 30 or 40 phone calls
to get one sentence uh the Twitter files
is
oh by the way here you know uh take a
laptop and look at 50 000 emails you
know full of all kinds of stuff and so
it's you know for for somebody like me
it's like a dream come true we get to
see all kinds of things get the answers
to questions that uh we've had for years
and it's it's been really incredible has
anything been surprising to you
um
a little bit I I think going into it I I
thought that the um that the
relationship between the security
agencies like the FBI and the DHS and
companies like Twitter and Facebook I
thought it was a little bit less formal
like I I thought maybe they had kind of
an advisory role and what we find is
that it's not that it's it's very
formalized they have
um a really intense structure uh that
they've worked out over a period of
years where they have regular meetings
um they have a system where the DHS
handles
um you know censorship requests that
come up from the states and the FBI
handles the international ones and they
all float all these companies and
um it's a big bureaucracy and we I don't
think we expect it to see that it's very
bizarre to me that they don't that they
would just openly call for censorship in
emails and these private Transmissions
but ones that are easily duplicated you
could send them to other people it could
it can easily get out like that they're
so comfortable with the idea that the
government should be involved in this
censorship of what turns out to be true
information especially in regards to the
hunter Biden laptop that they would be
so comfortable that they would just send
it in emails yeah yeah well that I think
that shows you the mentality right like
they they really genuinely felt that
they were impregnable that they don't
have anybody to answer to
um I mean a normal person doesn't put
incriminating things in emails because
we all have the expectation that someday
it might come come out you know but
these folks didn't act that way I mean
they you see I was I was especially
shocked by an email from a staffer for
Adam Schiff the Congress person the
California congressman and they're just
outright saying we would like you to
suspend the accounts of this journalist
and anybody who retweets information
about this committee you know I mean
this is this is a congress this is a
member of Congress yeah right most of
these people have legal backgrounds
they're they've got lawyers in the
office for sure
um and this is the this is the house
intelligence committee uh you would
think they would have better operational
security another moment that was
shocking to me
there was a um there's an email from an
FBI agent uh named Elvis Chan in San
Francisco
to Twitter and they're setting up this
signal Group which is going to include
all the top sort of censorship
Executives at all the big companies and
it's a Word document that has all the
phone numbers of all these important
Executives and the email just the
subject line reads
phone numbers uh right and then the word
doc is just called secret phone numbers
right
Quantico really you know I mean like I
mean even a journalist can't miss that
you know what I'm saying
call it something else you know I don't
know that that part of it was amazing so
strange it's so strange to get such a
peek because I don't think anybody ever
anticipated that something like this
would happen where Twitter would get
sold to an eccentric billionaire whose
intent on letting all the information
get released
yeah I mean I I think Elon Musk
essentially
he
he spent 44 billion dollars to become a
whistleblower of his own company yeah uh
and I mean I I don't really fully know
his motives in doing that um I think
he's got a pretty a developed sense of
humor though yeah uh and that comes
through I think he he gets a kick out of
seeing all this stuff come out on
Twitter which used to be the kind of the
private stomping ground of all these
whiny journalists and now here here is
all this information that is just
horrifying to all of them
um I mean that's 44 billion dollars is a
lot to spend on that thrill but I'm glad
he did well he truly believes that
censored social media is a threat to
democracy he really believes that
absolutely yeah and I believe it too
yeah I just don't have 44 billion
dollars right even if I did I'd be like
uh I don't want that heat right right
yeah I I don't I don't think that's what
I would spend it on but uh no he he
believes that I think he also
I think he also believes that the
credibility of these companies
can only be restored by telling people
what what they talk about in private or
what they have been talking about you
know with the government and that sort
of thing yeah so
um he might be right about that you know
we'll see I guess I think he is I mean
it's going to be interesting it's going
to be interesting to see how this plays
out there's an amazing amount of
resistance against him and you know
there's just the publicity campaign
against him has been fascinating to
watch people go from thinking that Elon
Musk is the savior that's bringing us
these amazing electric cars and
Engineering new reusable Rockets too
he's an alt-right piece of [__] who
wants Donald Trump back in the office
and it's like it's very wild the the the
speed with which they can sort of
Shuffle somebody into the Hitler of the
month club routine right like you know
we've always done this with foreigners
you know whether it's Noriega or Saddam
Hussein or milosevic or Assad or
whatever it is like we have a playbook
for cranking out negative information
about uh you know foreigners who get in
our way for whatever reason but now
we've we've kind of refined that
technique for domestic people who are
inconvenient you know I think they did
it with Trump obviously
um you know they try to do with Tucker
Carlson with you uh you know I mean you
got a taste of that for a few a few
times yeah it's interesting right uh and
then you know with with Elon yeah he
went from being the guy who made
electric cars sexy to like you know
something to the right of Victor Orbin
in in like 10 seconds it's it's amazing
it is amazing and the narrative is
spread through Progressive people well
they'll just say it now it it's like
they've reached the memo the memos got
to them and then they just I hear people
in La I hear people that I know like oh
Elon just so crazy it's like it was
something happened to him he went nuts
and he's a right winger now like how
what are you saying like what what
examples do you have like they don't
have an example they just have this
narrative that reach them the signal
like Elon Badd now all right run bad now
Elon bad now Elon bad now and they just
start saying it and you go like what
what examples are you using of like his
behavior well he let Trump back on the
platform okay well
the taliban's there right yeah exactly
you don't have a problem with the
Taliban the town pan just bought blue
check marks do you know that did they
really yes didn't know that they're
buying blue check marks so they could be
verified
um the the real terrorists
the [__] Taliban is not and nobody
has a problem with it the CCP is on
Twitter right no one has a problem with
it right but they're like Trump they'll
let Trump back on look
Trump is hilarious he's a ridiculous
person but don't you think it's better
that his tweets get out there and then a
bunch of people get to attack him in the
tweets and if those tweets that people
attack him with are good if people are
saying good things then those things get
retweeted and liked and then they rise
up to the top of the algorithm it's all
good like you need a voice against
someone like that you can't have that
guy howling into the wind on some Q Anon
forum and all those wackos just so
they're only talking to each other with
no pushback at all if you really don't
like Trump you want him on Twitter
absolutely you want that guy to have
some pushback you want people to be
talking against what he's saying you
want Twitter the real Twitter now which
will actually fact check everybody they
fact check Biden right they'll they'll
fact check him so if he says something
stupid they'll go no that's not what's
true here's what's true right and that
would be good and that was actually for
a while Twitter's official policy they
had something called the public interest
policy which specifically laid out
exactly what you said like when when a a
world leader no matter who it is says
anything we want it to be out there
because we want it to be debated we want
people to see it we wanted people to
talk about it we want people to reach
conclusions about it and one of the
things that we found in the Twitter
files was after January 6th they there
was this intense debate within the
company where they were basically saying
oh thank God we're going to repeal the
public interest policy or we're going to
poke a hole in it right
and no longer have that belief system
that just because somebody is a world
leader we need to hear what they have to
say so they invented a new
um a new policy called glorification of
violence or they they called it that and
essentially what they said was you you
had to look at Trump not in terms of
each individual tweet uh but in terms of
what they call the context surrounding
his whole career uh all the people who
followed him whether or not they were
violent whether or not they said the
things that were offensive it's like the
speech version of stochastic terrorism I
don't know if you ever heard that
terminal it's a stochastic terrorism is
this idea that
um you you can incite people to Violence
by saying things that aren't
specifically inciting but are
statistically likely to uh create uh you
know somebody who will do something
violent even if it's not individually
predictable and that's what they did
with Trump they basically invented this
concept that yes he may not have
actually incited violence but his whole
the whole totality of his Persona is is
inciting so we're going to strike him
and so they sort of massively expanded
the the purview of what of things that
they can censor just in that one moment
and it was it's you know you can see it
in these dialogues how they came to that
decision which is just fascinating and
they've never come out and said
we were misinformed that is not the case
there really wasn't this crazy collusion
between Russia and Donald Trump and in
fact there was some information that
seems to point to that Hillary Clinton
had involvement with Russia too and that
they've kind of all had involvement with
Russia and that this this wasn't some
Grand conspiracy to elect a Russian
puppet as the president United States
sorry yeah it was it was a three and a
half year sort of mass hysteria
experiment right and I mean this is one
of the things
it's one of the reasons I I got kind of
quietly moved out of mainstream
journalism right I didn't have
particular uh problem at Rolling Stone
but you know I I
early on in in the Trump years I
I said something wrong with the story I
I think there are elements of it that
aren't provable I don't think we should
be running this stuff you know and uh
then
uh before I knew it I was working
independently but anyway uh at the
Twitter files we've we're finding stuff
that now tells you absolutely like what
actually the truth was during that time
like for instance one of the big
rushigate stories uh was from early 2018
when Devin Nunes remember the he was the
Republican Congressman he was the head
of the house intelligence committee at
the time
he wrote a memo uh basically saying we
think they they faked fisa applications
we think the FBI used the steel dossier
to try to get surveillance Authority
against some Trump people like Carter
page and we think they lied and cheated
to do that
and so he submitted this classified memo
and Not only was he denounced everywhere
as a liar and wrong and all that but
there was this big story that was all
over the place that a hashtag
#release the memo
had been Amplified by Russian Bots
you probably don't remember this but but
this story was everywhere in January and
February of 2018
this idea that that uh released the memo
was basically a Russian operation and
that Nunes was
benefiting from it well I'm reading the
Twitter files I was looking for
something else entirely and then
suddenly we come across a string of
emails internally at Twitter where
Twitter where the Twitter officials are
saying you know we're not finding any
Russians at all behind this hashtag and
we told the members of Congress who
asked about this that there are no
Russians involved in this because
Dianne Feinstein Richard Blumenthal of
Connecticut they all came out with this
accusation about about it being linked
to Russia we told them that there's
nothing there and they they went and
they did it anyway you know and so there
are lots of stories like that now that
are kind of falling apart right